the latest is i just phoned to my high
command
and they say the area of blessam is
absolutely endangered we have a
100 meter absolutely no-go zone
from the rim of the actual sized hole
of this keysgruber they are
investigating and doing reconnaissance
missions with
unmanned aerial vehicles to check if
there are cracks in the ground because
the lighter of the afterbund
the the water authorities
who are in charge of monitoring the
river say
the ground is so unstable that the
hundred meter zone
um around the keys group might slip in
and then
drop off immediately so absolutely no go
area
a hundred meters away from the actual
hole
in the rest of blessing they are
investigating
with civil engineers
the state of the streets of the
buildings
and when and how it's safe to let
civilians
go back to their homes it could be it
could be days weeks or even longer
couldn't it
yes might be don't know i hope we will
make it but it's
absolutely uncertain at the moment we
have another problem now in afghan libla
it's the other side
there's a relatively new build home
welfare home for elder people
and in the basement cracks show up and
the engineers say these cracks are
widening so they have to evacuate this
home for all the people immediately
so the troubles are not over yet yeah
what sort of
difficulties are your crews facing i
mean they're
they're numerous aren't they especially
things like power lines are down there's
no communications uh sewers are running
in the streets
give me a sense of how tough the work is
the work the greatest problem the
biggest problem is
that this is too much to do for
the fire brigade it's it's
situation we have seen in tv but not in
our hometown
and there are many sites which
need to be yes
yes where you have to do to do work
you see here the bypass road with
which is blocked with by water by cars
by um
heavy um lorries and
500 meters away is bless them with the
the key screw with the
the sand hole it was a hole where you
gain sand for construction purposes and
we are here in the the right the old
rhine valley of the ice age and it's
all sandy ground and that is why the
water can
wash away the ground if there's a hole
on the other side you know
when you try to build a sand castle on
the north sea and the flood comes
the sand becomes wet it's completely
flat it washes
it it washes away and that is the
problem
we have here in an xxl size that the
ground is sandy and here's too much
water and it's it's too much
ground in motion
you